hello and welcome to this video playing
mr. X why's that well that's a new guy
[Music]
getting annoyed by the same thing I'll
play that bloody opening okay at least
not the d3 stuff again rather this this
very old-fashioned line and that game
before though those games are deeply
irritating so what's what's going on
here this is the specialty six stuff I
think it's very difficult for black to
win check yeah this is Sam this is the
way how this is played it's
unfortunately incredibly boring oh my
god this is the most boring position
ever well it takes a special kind of
player to play like that with white but
okay
[Music]
[Music]
maybe I should and I will continue to
play this to move 120 or something yeah
I don't know it's really nothing going
on I can try this still nothing going on
maybe can play like p3 year or something
[Music]
yeah I can claim a symbolic ischium very
symbolic mm-hmm okay well at least okay
he's got d5 unfortunately I don't know I
can't cannot go to five at least this
drops this this pawn down so we it's
actually something is actually happening
in this game not a lot but still so okay
Bishop d5 he likes he wants to check me
here and then enter on the seventh so
let's not allow that so either name I
have to go back here but what can you do
you would have to take care of them D
pawn somehow
it's a little bit a little bit more
comfortable for black hair but yeah even
this which is quite passive should be
yeah I should do the trick
so I go here preparing f6 and Bishop d5
[Music]
so what is he going for like rook c5
maybe okay
[Music]
Jim he's gotten himself into slide
issues here but still for example if he
goes d5 here I have two trade routes my
bishop takes has made and maybe d5 this
one okay
okay at least f6 is not that easily
played so what's the what's happening
okay not king of a rock give 5 negative
5 I mean I have this this root now to
potentially go to a 5 but that's really
really not much not much age six takes
and g6 is an interesting idea it's not
so easy um to put two let's try that
that at least gives some play in this
position now he just just add okay now I
can bring the King up here I mean not
that it is much but it's an additional
option at least
[Music]
yep that's possible so what now yeah
what if five also doesn't lead to
anything okay I can take yeah well okay
woop takes and then process 95 is
actually making some kind of sense
hmm yeah I should have thought about
this a little bit more medium okay check
[Music]
yeah as we said before very early on
there is not much going on
[Music]
[Music]
yeah cannot cannot do anything at all
you say anything I can do some eight
five five from that it doesn't doesn't
help at all
now just to draw what can you do draw
our game drawn and it wasn't born was
boring game ever yeah I'm actually gonna
build something but Jack it's so
difficult to make anything anything
serious all of it maybe take now yeah
this is this is probably better I didn't
really appreciate Jen can take oh I can
go f6 and win a pawn for nothing
yes now I didn't pay you at INSEAD yeah
this is this is dead no of course have
six yeah then this is still kind of I
mean hey you can still continue here
yeah I don't know he played the most
boring opening ever okay maybe I'm
making I can avoid Bishop d6 but it is
the best move objectively speaking and
it is equal this is the more the more
chaotic move even this is possible even
though it looks kind of strange yeah
check in here it's very difficult to do
something
Karina five or something like that but
this is just totally dead yeah
that sometimes happens here if you play
a 45 and interns in some lines white can
just kill the game this is why ya often
times it is said that before it's the
best move to play for a draw because in
many lines you can just completely empty
the boredom yeah that wasn't very
exciting so thanks for watching